hey guys I'm just McDonald a tease the
29th of January today and you are
watching games but news so we'd better
get into some story Dark Souls 2 s found
a way to make itself more difficult
because that was the thing that the
series was crucially missing out on that
difficulty comes from the fact that
other gamers can now infiltrate your
game even when you're not in your humans
date so in Dark Souls 2 you can be
killed put into a hollow state and
players will still be able to invade
your worlds are two down and kill you
again where as in the previous games
Demon's Souls and Dark Souls you could
never invade the game of colored players
unfortunately for those of you not big
on PvP or online features this is all
set to make dodging those facets of the
game all the more challenging before you
go freaking out or disconnecting your
gaming machine from the internet though
there is some comforting news when it
comes to this new PvP feature from
software have said that matchmaking will
still be based upon play a level but
will also incorporate how much time any
given player has put into the game on
top of that there are still going to be
penalties for players who invade and
lose and what the dev is calling
policemen against invaded Dark Souls 2
is also set to feature reworked soap
stones items for cooperative play where
time limits will depend upon the size of
the stone are you happy about the
changes we've been hearing about so far
and will you be picking yourself up some
dark souls 2 next up Nintendo CEO Satoru
Iwata may not be quitting after
revealing that we used losses but he
will be flashing his salary in half for
five months since their operating loss
for the last nine months of 2013 was
around 15 million they've done a great
job at spooking investors and causing
themselves general turmoil a wada has
confirmed he'll be taking the temporary
pay cut as will other members of the
Nintendo
board who are expected to have their
salaries taken down between twenty to
thirty percent as with most in Hindu
stories you guys have opinions ranging
from all-out hate to support for the
companies so let me know what you think
of a water and Nintendo's future the
Elder Scrolls online has released a
massive eight minutes EG trailer today
which has some of you super excited and
some of you still kind of skeptical the
lovely looking trailer is all pretty
graphics epic detail and giant monsters
it follows on from the last cg trailer
which you'll probably mistake it for
when you start watching and takes place
nearer to oblivion Sarah dill which
although I'm not a hundred percent sure
about the game looks really freaking
cool did you guys like the look of the
trailer and do you think elder scrolls
online is going to be a success or not
you can let me know either in the
comments down below or on my Twitter
where I'm at just McDonald that's all
the stuff I've got for you today but I
will leave you with some of this crazy
cinematic trailer so you can judge for
yourself of these things
you